this podcast and every other podcast I
make is supported by patreon if you want
to throw the patreon a dollar you'd be
helping to support these relatively
Niche shows that I intend to be very
educational and informative about the
games industry talking to a lot of very
cool people but there are other
memberships that include some special
bonuses too such as completely unedited
Q as ad free versions of content
unedited versions of shows and even the
ability to play games with me so if you
want to support some independent games
industry podcasts check out the link in
the description Hello everyone welcome
to another episode of video game writing
101 today I am joined by Gary Witter
Gary who are you and what do you do
uh is that how you is that how you start
everyone do you pretty much your bogus
question oh it makes it so much easier I
don't have to yeah it's good it's good
uh you threw it to me right away
um I'm a former video game journalist I
started out many many years ago as
editor-in-chief of PC Gamer magazine
that's what brought me here to the
United States uh and for the last uh uh
geez I want to say 20 years I have been
a screenwriter in Hollywood working
primarily in film and television but
also in video games I obviously do comic
books I'm a novelist I do all kinds of
writing mostly film and television but
because I had a whole career uh prior to
my Hollywood career as a video game
writer and because video games as we
know in Hollywood are like so the Venn
diagram is practically a circle at this
point there's a lot of crossover stuff
in the work that I do uh you are one of
the only guests I've had uh the only one
was Mitch Dyer who came from a press
background like me
um people ask me questions about it all
the time but I feel like I can't answer
as effectively as you might be able to
um what do you think is some of the
biggest differences between writing
press and screenwriting and do you think
those skills are transferable
not really I mean I think you can draw
or I mean you know I think like you know
as a Critic as a journalist you know
you're mostly writing kind of like
essays I guess and critiques and things
like that it's very different you know
non-fiction fiction are obviously very
different I didn't find the skills to be
transferable at all I worked as a games
journalist and a writer and also as a
film critic I edited a film magazine for
for some years even a Sports magazine
um uh for some years before I moved into
Hollywood and I didn't find I mean
obviously I think writing's writing like
you learn grammar and how to construct a
sentence and things like that but and I
guess there's an argument that when you
write an essay especially like a long
form essay you are telling a story right
there's a there's a there's a structure
to like a long to a long read essay and
so I think there are kind of like maybe
some very very basic Universal rules
about like what good writing is and
isn't in terms of how you engage a
reader get them you know excited right
away and get them you know to to read
all the way to the end that's true no
matter what you're writing but beyond
that I think they separate very quickly
and and the rules of and the things
you're concerned with when you're ready
infection I think are very very
different I agree with that but I also I
think I might have found them to be more
transferable than you did and I think it
was more
um because I've also been writing
fiction my whole life like that's where
I started before I did journalism and
then got back into fiction yeah me too
that probably makes sense like I was
writing short stories as a kid and all
that yeah that's what I did I used to
get I used to get bullied at school
because I used to play It's funny how I
turned out as a video game writer I I
would play video games back in the 80s
when I was a kid which games didn't
really have much of a story sorry Mario
the princess is in another castle like
that was video game story back in the
day and we were okay with it and I would
play these games that didn't really have
much of a story basically what would fit
on the back of like the cassette inlay
that's how old I am I used to play games
that came on on tape cassette that you
would load and so I would I would I
would kind of write the story in my head
I would do my own head Canon version and
fill out
I would write fanfic in my head and I
would I used to write my own little
fanfic versions of like infocom games
and things like that and
um I wrote that was Gemini fanfic I
could probably still find that they I
mean I've still got some I've still got
the very very first screenplay uh I ever
wrote back in 1988 that was based on a
1985 Commodore 64 game called paradroid
it's on this old yellowed uh dog-eared
paper I look at it now and I cringe but
like it you know for me it's a
historical artifact for first replay I
ever wrote but yeah that's how I got
started was writing video game fan
fiction and now and yeah you too and now
look at us yeah that's awesome yeah yeah
everybody starts somewhere um but I
think the things that I found
transferable were things that make a
good journalist I think are not that
different to things that make a good um
video game writer at least I know like
having written a few screenplays they
are well maybe I do write them all the
same way
um a lot of it is a lot more technical
than I think people think so a lot of
like structuring an essay as you said
for journalism is prioritizing what's
important to the reader and and what
order of the information comes in and I
think video games in again less so
screenplays come in the same way where
it's a lot of prioritizing it's making
sure that every single line is relevant
to the previous line is relevant to a
line that's going to happen 10 beats
down
um where I think when maybe if you
aren't a writer you'd have to throw it
in the audience for this you think that
you're just sort of creatively flowing
and I'm like I don't do very much of
that I do a lot of planning and a lot of
like reading a line and making sure that
it's exactly the way that character
would say it why would this character
use this word how do they phrase this
thing do they use these kinds of phrases
um which I again I didn't feel was super
dissimilar to journalism though
the point obviously and the purpose are
extremely different
um so what coming from that if you
started out fanfic writing screenplays
fanfic is a very dismissive way of
putting it but again but that's exactly
what it was back in the day
um what made you get into journalism in
the first place I was a video game nerd
as I said and I would write these kind
of head Canon fanfic video game stories
I grew up in the UK playing
um Commodore 64 and ZX Spectrum games as
as as you know
um in the the your kind of path of of
how you
kind of go up through the different game
machines through the 80s and 90s
different in the UK than I know it's
fascinating to know what it's like what
it was like in Australia growing up
because in the UK like we did the
Nintendo and the Sega Master System and
the Supreme those things existed but
like most kids of the 80s played learned
to play games on the Commodore 64 or the
ZX Spectrum rather than on the game
consoles
okay so I didn't mean to I didn't mean
to age you up to reminding me but like
but like what what were your what were
your what were your game systems when
you were a kid yeah Nintendo was huge um
yeah but it's interesting if you look at
the release date of a lot of 64 games
uh that different in Australia Australia
had later releases than even North
America in a lot of cases
um I think the 64 even came out later in
Australia so we were delay it on a lot
of you guys got everything late yeah
pretty much we don't need more and
overpriced as well right Australian game
prices are a joke 110 120 a lot of money
that said everybody earns more money so
it kind okay balances out like all right
like I was at like we start working at
13 nine months in Australia I was at
McDonald's I don't know why it's 39
months it's like they account for the
time in the womb
yeah so I started straight away at
McDonald's and I think I was like my
first job getting like 10. I want to do
a whole podcast it's just about I now
obviously we're not going to do this but
I just don't know how a whole
conversation about you working at
McDonald's when you were 14 years old a
great time it was fun I feel like you've
got you must have stories is somebody uh
I worked the the drive through for the
most part and somebody threw a milkshake
at me once that was my like most
defining day oh my God like they they
bought it
I don't even remember why they were mad
maybe that car declined and I had to
take a different card or something so
they got it and then they drove back
around through the drive-through threw
it at me
it's a lot of effort for a thing you
bought maybe they didn't like it I don't
remember but uh did you did you build
the Big Macs or did you know I never
worked in the kitchen okay um either
check out on the front I did a lot of
cleaning did clean up a lot of vomit and
I do think that um it defines you as a
person if you have yeah retail and clean
up vomit I I don't think you should be a
writer you've got to have that
experience makes writing more
interesting okay can you imagine people
like who just write and that's all
they've ever done like rich kids
you have to have you have to have some
experience life experience to draw on
otherwise what are you doing yeah you
have to be able to relate to somebody
about something um and then I did the
drive through so I was just taking the
orders which I I actually really enjoyed
doing I had the little headset thing yep
and I would sit there and uh organize
when there was no one there organize all
of the money so that all of like
Australian money has like a little
window on it all the windows were the
same it's the most boring thing in the
world to just because I had nothing else
to do while I was sitting there in any
case
that's where I came from and now this
podcast is about McDonald's you start
working
terrible habit of like derailing
conversations it's fine it's it's this
is supposed to be more like getting a
coffee with someone than it is like an
interview so it works but well we're
certainly doing that so okay but I'm
going to get us back on track to answer
your question
um uh I grew up uh playing video game uh
computer games I was obsessed with them
and initially I wanted to make them
again I come from a generation where
computer games used to be made by one
person like one person could program a
Commodore 64 or a spectrum game right it
was just one person that did everything
because the games were so basic you know
you didn't you didn't really maybe two
people but it was like they were a lot
of the game the kind of the game
creators that were like famous of that
period it's not teams it's one person
now of course obviously it's massive
teams there's still
occasionally now you have like an indie
game that breaks through like one or two
people made it uh like vampire survivors
right one guy right really yeah
yeah
isn't that crazy isn't that crazy super
impressive but my favorite episode that
was my game of the year for last year
survivors wow it's just the best damn
um and so I was and so I wanted to
initially I wanted to make games I
wanted to program and design my own
games and uh I bought a book on Assembly
Language and machine code because that's
what you would use to make these games
uh and I very very quickly realized that
um I'm very very
um right-brained which you know you know
the right brain is the creative half and
the left half is the left side's the
rational Hive so like for example I'm
very very good with imaginative things
and Abstract Concepts but like logic and
puzzles and things like that and math I
can't do like when my wife and I play uh
I remember when I was I was playing
Uncharted a couple of years ago the more
recent one and I would do all the
scaling and the combat and then we would
get to a puzzle I would give it a
controller to my wife and she would
solve the puzzle for me I'm fascinated
by Logic and puzzles like I'm fascinated
by mathematics I'm fascinated by chess
and things like that but I can't
actually do it same and maybe it may be
the reason why I'm fascinated is because
I know it's impenetrable to me but I'm
very good with abstract imagine relative
type things
um and so what I realized was okay so
that's never going to work because I'm
just not technically minded uh and so I
thought but I used to be obsessed with
video game magazine so you grew up on
this magazine called zap64 which was
like the predominant uh Commodore 64
magazine of the 1980s and I wanted to
review I could review the games I could
write about them I am good at writing uh
I knew that that was like English was
the only uh class in school that was
ever interested in I would write my
little sad fan fictions and things like
that and like it was the only it was the
only school report I ever got back like
oh Gary's a really good writer
um and so I thought well maybe I could
review the games and write about them
maybe I could get a job on a magazine
now don't forget this is all
pre-internet this is just print is the
only thing there's no easy way yes
writing job was print
yeah still happening I mean yeah yeah
we're both we're both old school to to
different to different degrees and I
remember distinctly of standing and
sitting in my parents kitchen with an
old uh typewriter and typing out a uh a
mock review of a game called
International karate that I was a big
fan of and I put put it in envelopes and
I sent it off to Commodore user and
zap64 and CVG magazine and different
places and one of the places responded
uh and 15 years old I got a job right
out of school as a um freelance game
reviewer for a magazine called Commodore
user and that was my first foot in the
door and then
so I was doing I was literally doing my
exams in the afternoon I would do my
gcses
um it was a general certificate of
secondary education I would do my my
kind of high school exams at 15 years
old in uh the morning and then the
afternoon I would go to the Commodore
user offices and they would give me
games to bring home and review that's
amazing and then in it I got because I
hated school hated it yeah primarily for
two reasons a I'm very orthod didactic
which means I don't do well in
structured learning environments you
can't teach me anything I'd much rather
learn it I learn by doing doing and
failure and experimentation
um which is why I've never been good at
like reading books on screenwriting or
going to seminars and things like that
it all when I when I go to one of those
places like the person trying to teach
me just ends up sounding like the
teacher from the Peanuts cartoon
I just I don't I don't absorb any of it
sure but I I learned just by well that
didn't work let's throw something else
and you kind of do it the old-fashioned
way and also because I was bullied
terribly in school because I was a nerd
before it was fashion or be a nerd I was
really skinny a terrible acne I had no
confidence I was into Star Wars and Star
Trek and Marvel and DC and all this kind
of stuff and that's cool now right but
like it wasn't when I was a kid and I
got beat up and like I remember one time
somebody
um uh uh uh
smashed the the wheel on my bike that I
would drive to school because I was a
nerd and kind of stuff and to this day
you'll notice in my writing to this day
like like bullying and standing up to
bullies is a big theme in my writing I
even Rogue one to me is a story about
standing up to bullies like what is the
Empire if nothing but a big bully sure
it's more like the little guy stands up
to right the Rebellion can I ask a side
question real quick yeah that someone
I've always wanted to ask because okay
it's always confused me so Star Wars was
already cool when I was in school I was
born in 1993. Star Wars was sorry it was
never not cool that was my question is
because Star Wars you know we talk about
the Star Wars nerd being bullied
but Star Wars was like one of the
highest grossing film releases and has
made more money than almost anything
else even from day one against Star Trek
how was Star Wars not cool when it was
always that popular I don't think it was
just it was like it was just one
component of the many many of the nerdy
things because I you know and video
games were cool right I was into video
games video games have always been cool
with kids they've never been uncool but
I don't know it would make me for
playing video games in high school and
that happened well again the rules are
different for you right unfortunately
again because you know it's it's there's
a there's a double standard uh in in
effect but no it was just it was it was
it was a number of things my nerdiness
being just one of them uh and I think
you know there's I was just one of those
I was I was just a spotty skinny gangly
awkward kid that the other kids thought
it was fun to pick on but the nerdiness
was definitely one one aspect of it
um and so yeah so you'll you'll see that
you'll see that um like gundog the
podcast that I just did last year is
absolutely big like literally the the
the the the the book comes out in July
the dedication on the front page says
dedicated to my parents who taught me to
stand up to bullies like that whole
thing is about about that that and it's
a I can't even watch uh scenes in movies
and television shows when a kid's
getting bullied like I get very
triggered by it because it's like a
deep-seated thing with me uh and I won't
and now and because of that now I've
almost over compensated as an adult and
I often have a very combative and
volatile personality because like I
decided a long time ago that I would not
take any [__] from anyone ever and and
so like I often get into trouble because
I I push back on people like too much at
least know yourself what's that at least
you know yourself you know what yeah and
you know I'd rather do that than roll
over and take a bunch of [__] from
people
um and but it took a long time to get
there and there's a lot of kind of you
know all of that there's like trauma
underneath all of that yeah pretty
deeply you always get this deep do you
get a psychology sometimes I guess I
feel like I'm talking to my therapist
right now
I'm
no this is I let people treat me like
crap but I don't even really know you
die oh I do I let people treat me like
absolute [__] and I'm always like oh
maybe they were having a bad day like
that's what I'm like in the real world
at least it's a problem you're someone I
mean I don't know you terribly well but
in the time I've known you strike me as
one of those people that doesn't take
[__] from anywhere yeah I take a lot of
[__] because because I'm unaffected by a
lot of [__] though you can treat me
terribly and I'll be like oh just gonna
let rolls off you pretty much and thus I
let people repeatedly treat me like [__]
and they go oh
but maybe they were having a bad time I
mean I I always try to remember that you
know every other thing they say about
like everyone that you meet is fighting
a battle that you know nothing about and
you try to you know take that into
consideration yeah um but honestly that
only goes so far sometimes a [__] is
just a [__] yes and you know they
deserve to be called out
um
where were we bring us back how did you
get into writing in the first place
which we did Cover as a 15 year old so
50 so 15 so the way that the way that my
birthday fell and the way that the
schooling system works in the UK or at
least used to I know if it's still now
that way now but in the 1980s you your
primary education ended at 16 and then
if you chose to you could do two extra
years
um
what are called your a levels and you go
from 16 to 18 you do it you do another
level of education and then after that
if you choose to you go to you go to
university
um but in the UK and again maybe it's
changed but when I was a kid there is
nothing like the stigma
I don't know if it's a stigma but
there's an expectation in the UK in the
US that you go to college right and if
you don't you're somehow it's like that
area or a drop out or not fully educated
yeah and every time I've had it every
time I've ever had to fill out a form
that you know an American form that says
what's your level of Education it just
is like high school did that make
getting a Visa harder
um no because well I mean okay let's
have this conversation this is
fascinating as well I always thought
this was backwards so to get my Visa
back in the day
um you had to have either three uh
either four years of
uh uh college
or 12 years of practical experience in
the relevant field and I always thought
that should be reversed because to me
the Practical experience is worth more
than the college I would agree I had
four years of University and I would
have had six years practical experience
at that point I think I think college
can prevent can prepare you for certain
things but it doesn't really prepare you
for the real world I think It prepares
you to socialize there is there is like
an academic education that you get but
like once you actually get thrown into
the labor force and like the real world
hits you I don't know how well College
really prepares I was studying at
University in my bachelor's um
well I majored in
entertainment writing which is the
screenwriting part of everything and
journalism and I was doing journalism at
the same time my source of income was
journalism while I was studying
journalism and I realized that I was
taking lessons from people who had no
practical experience they'd only studied
the course and yes I had more experience
than a lot of the people I was learning
journalism from but it was a very weird
experience and I've always said and I
love that that you have this perspective
that I value the time that I went to
school and the things that I learned but
I don't think it's necessary and another
thing that you've touched on here that I
think is really important for anyone who
wants to get into writing some people
the way that they think the way that
they learn is not compatible with the
education system don't think if you're
watching this and you want to get in a
video again writing that because you
don't have a degree or that you don't
learn that way that you can't get into
it because you absolutely can just a
different facet no we've we've stumbled
onto a subject that I have thought about
and have a lot to say about over the
years I don't know if you've ever seen
the Rodney Dangerfield movie back to
school where so to run Andy Dangerfield
is you know he's just incredibly
successful he's very obnoxious but this
incredibly successful business kind of
mave and he runs this like hugely
successful
um uh chain of like retail stores like
selling clothes to like over oversized
men like big and tall okay clothing
stores and he's worth a fortune
um and his kid he's having trouble in
college and to try and help his kid he
says I'll enroll in college with you as
well and I'll be like you're you're
buddy and so this like 50 year old guy
goes to college and you know it's Rodney
Dangerfield so he rubs everyone the
wrong way and that's the that's the
general gist of it but there's a scene
in it that and there's a scene in the
Tom Cruise movie Cocktail that's very
similar to this but the Rodney
Dangerfield version is better where he's
sitting in this business class and this
very kind of Stuffy business professor
is trying to talk it he's trying to talk
to the class about how business works
but Rodney danger would just as a guy
who's actually run a business in the
real world for many years have been
super successful at it is pushing back
on everything going like that works in a
classroom but none of this shit's gonna
work once once you you hit reality yeah
and he thought about well what about
what about the what about the um what
about the what about the teamsters you
got to pay those guys off like where's
that in the in the in the class you know
and all this kind of stuff and it's
there's a big difference between that
and uh you know academic learning and
what happens in the real world and I
wish that there had been a class
throughout my degree where they taught
us how to deal with being a freelancer
that is such a big reality of being a
writer there are no classes about that
and it's like if I were to structure
that I would be like here's a whole
semester on how to manage yourself as a
freelancer and how to pitch because that
stuff that I learned yeah because the
writing is only a very small part of it
totally right it was just less of a part
of it than pitching and we should talk
about pitching because that's a whole
other thing and it's something I've
learned a lot about over the I used to
be terrible at it I've become I've
become very good at it but I'm 20 years
ago it took me 20 years to get good at
it I think this is why okay so bring it
back to writing this is why I'm very
very skeptical about screenwriting books
and screenwriting seminar ours
particularly those that are written and
taught by people that have never
actually had anything produced in the
business like I remember seeing a book a
few years ago it was like the you know
the secrets to uh writing a billion
dollar Blockbuster movie and I looked
around the bar I've never heard of this
guy I've been in there like trust me
this guy's done anything I've heard of
him and I'm looking at his credits he's
got no credit he's never had a movie
produced I'm like man if you actually
hold on a second you actually have the
secrets to writing a billion dollar
movie why don't you go do that why are
you writing way more money in it than
writing this book
um and so and so like there are
screenwriting books that I recommend and
and and and and you know think things I
will send people to go read but they're
generally from people that have actually
been there and done it and talked to
other writers I've talked to people like
Craig Mason you know who's a show runner
on Last of Us and other writers will
tell you that there's a group of there's
many of us in the business who are in
the trenches who work in screenwriting
who have done it for 20 years who know
how it actually works that look a lot
look a lot at a lot of these like
seminars and courses and books and Rick
recognize them for exactly what they are
which is snake oil Style by people who
don't know what the [__] they're talking
about you know I of all the writers that
I do that I know or that I'm like even
good friends with I don't think I know
any of them that attend those seminars
and I wouldn't be surprised if a lot of
them are run by people who are trying to
make money off of
the appeal of Hollywood of people who
want to work in Hollywood
um the only thing that I know that
people consider to generally be pretty
useful is uh like DC I know has a
course that they offer to people you
can't apply you have to be nominated for
um being a showrunner they're like show
runner Academy things that are supposed
to be super valuable that some of the
companies hold that people speak pretty
highly of but of all the writers I know
I don't know of any of them that attend
seminars and I mean look it's I I always
say it's different for everyone and this
is why I'm very wary of of rule books
and like you've got to do it this way or
that way I think there are Universal
good best practices But like everyone
does it differently like like you said
earlier that you outline in great detail
yeah I I don't see it depends on the
pressure but I don't like the the thing
that I just recently wrote I wrote
completely by the seat of the pants and
I think it's probably one of the best
things I've ever written sometimes it
just works out I'm doing that right now
and the problem that I have with doing
that with this is just a screenplay that
I'm writing that I have been for the
last couple of months is that I keep
going back all the time because I'm not
planning ahead I just keep rereading it
and I feel like I'm writing less than I
am reading and keeping like hang on
right when did I do this part okay that
happened there this needs to happen here
whereas if I have an outline I don't do
that so much I think you know for most
things I have at least like for example
for the Book of Eli I had the outline it
was it was just you know it was a beachy
it was one page because that movie
doesn't have a lot of moving Parts in
terms of plots a very very basic plot
and so all like I needed to know where I
was going I needed to know what
beginning middle and end I needed a
basic spine but again for me just for me
the way that I write what I did what
I've discovered and sometimes you have
to write an outline because it's a
contractual step like they want to see
an outline before they'll commence you
to script and so I'll do it because I
have to
um but I don't I don't find it useful
because just the way that my brain works
when I'm writing an outline I'm writing
what I'm doing is I'm writing about the
thing that I'm going to write it's not
the actual end product and I find that
one when I'm kind of one step removed
from the actual writing I'm not fully
engaged and so what I discover is uh all
of my best moments of Discovery and like
oh I just had a brilliant idea that
happens when I'm actually in the page
yeah actually on the page
um everybody who isn't familiar um and
I'm pretty sure this is correct Gary
Book of Eli was your first like sold
screenplay correct wasn't my first sold
one but it was the first thing to get
made to get made okay and that was right
after you had or you were still working
journalism or you just stopped no I was
long out by that point I left in I left
in 2001. and I was in I started
screenwriting in 2001 2002 and I sold my
first thing in around 2003 and then I
kind of batted around the minor leagues
for uh about four years doing a little
uncredited rewrite jobs and things like
that and getting paid but not getting
not getting paid but not getting made
yeah and then I wrote Eli in 2007 and
that
that was when my career really started
gotcha so how does the press work of
again we've just jumped off of two
things here but
um of
getting something sold what like you
know there are a million books about
that and a million seminars about that
how did you do it the first time
a lot I mean again when I did it
you used to be able to submit things
I mean for me I mean for me now it's
easy right because I'm established and I
just give something to my agent and they
go and they'll go try and sell it like I
have people know who I am sometimes I
can just call a pretty I've been like
I've been doing this for 20 years I
could just call a producer or a guy at a
studio and say hey you want to read this
I mean I will always go through my agent
for whatever reason if I want to I can
just talk to people directly because
people know who I am but before uh but
I'm sorry but before that but before
that it was much more difficult and I
don't know either I wouldn't even know
how to advise people to do it now
because the internet has changed a lot
it's much easier now like when I was
when I first started writing it was hard
to get your hands on scripts to even
like figure out like what a good script
you know how it's formatted what it
looks like because that's what I mostly
tell people do I say don't read a lot of
books about screenwriting but read a lot
of screenplays like find this green
place to your favorite movies and like
see how they were written on the page
and understand how because because you
know this Alana like screenwriting has a
particular Rhythm and a Cadence to it
it's not like any other form of writing
it's about trying to it's basically your
objective is to try to get the reader to
imagine the movie in their head as as
vividly as possible using as few words
as possible right and it's a very
specific discipline uh and it's
something you can get very good at I
would I would I would I always Point
people to this uh it's very easy to find
go find the original draft of alien
written by David guiler and Walter Hill
it's almost like a [__] Haiku it uses
so few words but but you but you so
vividly see the movie in your head it's
an absolute
um my recommendation is always the
Godfather read the Godfather's
screenplay especially because it was
adapted but I'm in the habit of doing
that and I think I mentioned this on
Twitch recently of any uh movie that I
like I and if I like the screenplay I
will immediately go find it if I can
yeah
and I was like holy [__] this screenplay
and immediately went and read it and
it's fascinating to see again it's
always interesting how it works on the
page
don't take long to read
a good screenplay and again this is this
is a really easy way to identify an
amateur screen screenwriter from a
professional is if there's I don't know
if people even use this term anymore but
when I was coming up there used to be
this term too much black there's too
much black and what they mean by that is
the writing is too dense if I'm going
through a screenplay and I'm seeing like
thick paragraphs of text that this
person does not know how to write
because you're using too many words I
guarantee you as an experienced screen
screenwriter I can take that eight I can
take that eight to ten lines I've seen
description and turn that into one or
two yeah and that's then that's the
discipline that you develop you should
probably you never really need to have a
paragraph on a screenplay there's more
than three lines life I'm going over
three lines I'm doing it wrong yeah and
you want you want it to be Breezy you
want the Riders to be able to like skip
through it very very video games are
pretty much the same yeah you know if
you have a paragraph you're taking
someone else's job away from them to be
honest and yeah and they're not they're
not novels
um you know you have to learn and you
know again and I don't want to say I
don't want to sound like too
like follow myself or anything but the
the truth is this the the rules change
as you become more established the more
established you become the more you can
break the rules sure when you are a new
writer you do have to kind of adhere to
most of I think most of the rules that
the basic best practices that that are
out there but then as you become more
established you get more
um
you know like Hank Aaron held the battle
wrong right but he he own runs anyway
like a batting a batting teacher would
look would have looked at Hank Aaron
says you're doing that all wrong but he
would say okay but watch this and he
would hit a home run I'm glad you
elaborated because I don't know [__]
about baseball I was like who is that
and what are you talking about okay got
it yeah but you know if you find what
for you the rules don't the rules don't
matter anymore and like the last couple
of things that I've written
um I uh you know I've broken any number
of rules earlier in my career would I
would have been very squeamish about in
The Book of Eli you know there's a
there's a famous screenwriting book
called save the cat by a guy called
Blake Snyder and it's bandured around a
lot by you know oh you've got to read
save the cat you got to read this book
and that book and it's one of the ones
gets banded around a lot I haven't read
it so I don't know maybe there's some
good
um uh
advice in there save the cat for people
that aren't familiar with it basically
means that when you introduce your
character at the beginning of the movie
you should you need to have them do
something sympathetic or demonstrate
some kind of likable or sympathetic
trait so that you recognize that that
you are on their side a good example is
in the Disney movie Aladdin right he
starts he steals the piece of bread but
then he gives it to a little kid who
needs it needs it more than him that's
the save the cat moment literally taking
the cat out of the tree the book is
actually more about business than it is
about uh writing funnily enough right
interesting uh but you know obviously
with that rule is it is it that's a
creative rule about like you your your
character needs to do something
sympathetic save the cat
the very first screenplay that I have
had made the Book of Eli he [__]
kills a cat on page one he does the
exact opposite of saving he [__]
murders it and eats it and that
screenplay got made with oscar-winning
actors and went on to do very well there
he is right behind me there and you know
it gave me the career that I have today
so rules I think rules are good right up
until the point where you realize
there's an instance where breaking them
is actually better totally than adhering
to the rule and again as you become more
experienced you develop a better sense
for when it's okay
um to do that so we're talking a lot
about screenwriting how much do you
think
screenplay varies or differs from video
games in your experience really depends
on the kind of game that you're writing
yeah I think if you're writing something
somewhat linear like God of War or Last
of Us or Uncharted where I don't mean to
sound reductive because I know I know it
isn't as simple as this but I feel
they've got a war
if you did as much as I can say that
that what we write looks pretty similar
to a screenplay but I'm just saying in
terms of like is basically a screenplay
or a TV series
you know broken down into these little
bite-sized chunks right and and and and
interspersed with gameplay and part of
the Artistry of that is figuring out
what's the right ratio right when do
okay when do we next go to Story how
much how much story do we want to tell
in this next piece before we go back to
the gameplay how much story do we want
to tell emergently within the gameplay
because that's obviously a thing as well
right the kind of the immersive
storytelling that just happens as you're
playing uh but you look at something
like Last of Us and people have done
this right they just cut together all
the cutscenes in The Last of Us and you
could watch it like it's a movie and it
basically Works
um and so it's not radically different
in that way and if I were to do any more
video game writing work it's something
I've kind of moved away from a little
bit to be honest but if I were to do
if I would we're enticed to go back and
write a video game it would be something
that is more like Last of Us or
Uncharted or God of War where I can
approach it just like a screenplay where
I've just got to figure out how to break
it into episodic pieces
um unlike the experience I had on The
Walking Dead which don't get me wrong
that was a brilliant experience we won a
lot of awards and you know it's been
great for me but that game because of
the the the degree to which it branches
and you can tell your own story and just
the technical side again this is where
where the left side of my brain starts
to shut down when you think about oh but
if he said that in the previous scene
then that branch is not valid and now
you have to do this and I wrote episode
four of season one of The Walking Dead
where by the time there's a there's a
scene at the end where Lee spoiler alert
after he gets bitten has to go find
Clementine who's been kidnapped to that
point and he asks other members of the
group that are with him if they're going
to come with him and at that point the
game does a calculation which is the
subtotal of every single decision you've
made with every character up until that
point and also how they interrelate with
other characters like yeah if you were
nice to this guy maybe he'll come with
you or if you weren't maybe he won't
that's simple enough but it's also like
if that character doesn't like this guy
this other character and this
character's coming with you now that guy
doesn't want to go because he doesn't
like that other and it's like the Venn
diagram but sort of the event but like
the flow chart of it all is so it's so
mind-bogglingly complex and and just and
just and the other thing is just the
volume of writing because you have to
write eight ten different versions of
every scene all the different ways that
they can Branch out and play like the
the first draft that I wrote Of The
Walking Dead was like 600 pages long wow
for yeah if that was a TV episode it'd
be a tenth of that yeah because you have
to write every possible permutation and
so in terms of volume and in terms of
like logical construction it's a
nightmare it would be very very it's
incredibly satisfying when the game
comes out and it works I remember
watching all the Let's Plays and
watching people agonize over the
decisions that we had built and having a
ton of fun with that
um but getting there is really really
hard so for me I I I I would I would be
happy to do more game writing but if
it's but it would need to be something
that's more in the kind of the linear
yeah side because that I think I love to
play The More Adventurous kind of
narrative games and I think that all of
the most exciting possibilities in
writing right now are actually on the
video game side because film and
television those are mediums that have
been around for almost you know like
almost 100 years like film's more than
100 years old TV's come out will be
almost 100 years old pretty soon like
you can still do amazing like Innovative
things in film but the the the the
formula is as you said is pretty
established whereas in video games I
think we're still kind of in the silent
movie era of like figuring out what we
can do with the tools and what what what
does it mean that we can it's only gonna
mean that we but what's interesting to
me is I think about this as a lot is
that when each new storytelling medium
comes along it always starts out by
mimicking the storytelling medium that
came before it so for example like what
did we have you know in the beginning
well you know around a campfire but like
in terms of like actually scripted
stories like people stood on a stage
right and we would watch a Shakespeare
play or whatever
um and when film first came along what
did it do it mimics that right it just
had a camera essentially in the front
row of the theater watching actors
perform on a stage but then very quickly
people began to realize oh wait hold on
a minute we can put the camera anywhere
we want we can cut we can edit we can
develop our own cinematic Language by
putting the camera anywhere we want and
we can jump from one period to another
and we can use that to tell a more
interesting story and the language of
cinema cinema began to emerge
fast forward to like the
1990s I guess when CD-ROM became became
a thing and we realized that we could
film live actors and do more adventurous
stuff with stories what did we do we
copied film we did we made interactive
movies which weren't really that
interactive and they were pretty shitty
as movies and so we had to kind of go we
had to realize that no that's not the
thing rather than try to copy Cinema how
do we lean into the things that the into
the unique tools that video games offer
us which is interactivity branching
non-linear non-linear non-linearity and
now we're starting and now we're
starting to see the language of video
games such but again we are still we're
still banging rocks together yeah
figuring out how to do it we're
absolutely in the silent movie era of
video games 20 30 years ago I'm fat I'll
be fascinated to see 20 30 years from
now where we are narratively because
we're still figuring it out yeah but
um but you know there is amazing there
are amazing people working in the field
of video games narratively telling
stories that can only be told in video
game form because they only work if you
use those tools journey and journey is a
great example uh I I think a lot about
braid which you know just incredible
things uh I think about The Artful
Escape that does one of my favorite
games in the last couple of years
um and you know we could we could go
down a rabbit hole of mentioning many
others as well uh but we're still just
at the beginning of that process and
while I think that that is where all the
really adventurous stuff and Discovery
and exploration and evolution is going
to happen in writing
I'll happily play those games but I'm
too lazy to be a part of that episode
I'll just play them yeah it is it is a
that's that's what excites me about
working in video games that's what I
love about it is that like we're only
moving in a direction I said to you I
was just on um I was just doing this
radio thing for ABC in Australia is what
I just came from and I was just ending
up like enthusing about how video games
are just starting out and I can't fathom
what games look like in 20 years which
is exactly what you've just said I think
that's so cool in terms of Storytelling
it's like what are they gonna look like
we just don't know yet I can't add VR
into the mix because I think we're in
the silent movie era in VR as well like
we're still figuring out but we will
Fitness
but we but we will get there and and I
and I think that you know the kind of
Storytelling that is going to be
prevalent
I I still think it's decades away but
yeah I do think we will get to the point
with the idea of watching like a linear
pre-bait story on a flat screen is going
to seem very quaint to like my kids when
they're my age you know what I mean
excuse me God uh but that kind of thing
that you're talking about which is like
more immerse emergent um which is the
thing I feel really strongly about I I
if I have an agenda in video game
writing it is that I would like to tell
as much of a story as possible through
gameplay without cutscenes like I feel
very strongly can we say this through
gameplay without it needing to be a
cutscene can we make sure the player has
control I feel very strongly about that
and I think it's something that we're
only going to see more and more and more
of us as complicated um as it is it's
Half-Life right like I was like you took
the words right in my mouth I'm gonna
say Half-Life does an amazing job of
telling a story where the main character
never speaks and there's never a cut
scene but you get a full story yeah and
that's incredible it does and that
game's and that game's what 25 years old
now
I don't know how to mute my Apple watch
Gary do you know how to mute an Apple
Watch yes um flip up flip and there's
like a little there's a thing that looks
like a little bell and click on that
Bell thank you
yeah and I didn't know how to re-mute it
um because the meetings just started uh
uh what was I talking about before I had
to mute my Apple watch yeah the issue
with Half-Life I think is that um
there's like a
it's not necessarily leader narrative
dissonance but I disconnect because the
player can jump around a dramatic scene
you're locked in a room but you can
still Jump Around in Circles which means
that they can kind of ignore the context
of that scene how do you make a player
through gameplay do something that is in
line with the narrative bit that is
being told at that exact same point in
time and I think it's really interesting
where I struggle and it's something that
I don't know why game developers still
hold on to this because they still use
it a lot and I feel like we should have
figured out I don't know the answer I
feel like there has to be a better one
is like for example a big pet peeve of
mine is audio logs um like I underst
that's you know oh here's a cassette
player and someone's like like someone's
left an audio log and I understand
that's how they're like parceling out
the story but my brain can't not think
about like what was the context in which
this person decided to record this audio
like it makes no sense
no I don't either and I I don't think
they're a good way to tell a story and
there has there just has to be a better
way I don't know what it is yet but the
audio logs thing to me is so played out
at this point well and they're also
usually pretty optional right they're
not even entirely necessary
um I think that they like served an
interesting purpose and you're right
that they take you out of the scene like
in BioShock which is the one that really
popularized that I think I think in that
world because you are with a bunch of
Scholars who I would buy would record
themselves being expensive it kind of
makes sense in that Universe um a lot of
other cases like in Callisto protocol
again why why did you record this other
than you wanted a player to listen to it
later like it doesn't make any sense I
do like games where you can go through
somebody's computer like definitely
doing that where you can read their
emails I think definitely did a really
good job of that because you in
character read these the I don't know
what they call um like Visionaries I
think they're called arguing with each
other
um and then you see them realize that
you're reading the emails as well like I
really like that touch where you can
choose to dig through somebody's
computer because I feel like what we
have in our PC is probably is pretty
telling like the amount of like games
that I have installed is even going to
give you a picture of who I am right
like the other the other Trope that I
think has become very overused is the
idea that you've always got someone in
your ear on a radio talking you through
everything yeah and again that that to
me is like less of a stretch because I
think there are often times when you can
you know contrive the story in such a
way that it makes sense you've got
someone in your ear I think we still
keep falling back on these same tired
ways to to
um to present story when I don't know I
just feel like eventually we're going to
push Beyond this we will and I think
it's again I think it's exciting
um but uh for context Gary because I
realized I didn't ask usually I would at
the start of the show and I should have
uh what games have you worked on
um lots of different ones in lots of
different capacities the one that I'm
most well known for is
um I was uh
um one of the story is on the main story
team uh for the walking tow truck games
The Walking Dead Season one and I wrote
one of the it helps write the whole
story or five episodes uh as well as the
DLC 400 Days and I wrote episode four
yeah
um and that was as you remember I was
like more than 10 years old now but that
was incredibly uh successful on tons of
awards I have my name on a bafta because
of it because we want a bafta for best
narrative
um and I'm very very proud of that uh
since uh and then beyond then
um I I worked on Duke Nukem Forever back
in the day in a in a you know when they
when they finally finally released the
game they credited everyone that ever
worked on every version of it so there's
a massive long stroll of everyone and my
name is in there somewhere even though
there's again none of my DNA in the
actual finished game that was made
um I worked on the original prey back in
the day I worked on the original Gears
of War back in the day again just very
very early World building stuff
um I was a story consultant on uh Halo
five guardians I would I would just sit
in a story room with them and and kind
of like break story with them and
suggest ideas but I didn't actually
write any of the stuff in the game just
kind of help them figure out what they
wanted to do and then I guess most
recently I were did some very very early
foundational kind of World building lore
stuff on uh for spoken that just came
out yeah so I've seen uh uh credit you
as one of the writers for for spoken on
Twitter I think but I'm of the
understanding that you also didn't
actually write any dialogue for that
either right
I mean I I don't think so I I I remember
not right I I mean I never wrote an
actual line of dialogue but at the same
time I haven't seen the finished game I
don't know I've not played it so I I
honestly don't know I think I'm credited
as like original Concepts or something
like that just to be clear so what
happened was um Square came to me like
five six years ago and said we have this
idea
um but it's just a germ of an idea would
you be help would you be willing to help
us like build out the world and the and
the the mythology and the story and I
went away and came up with some ideas
for them presented them they liked them
and they said would you run a writer's
run uh to like really build it out and
so I love writer's rooms it's one of my
favorite places to be is like when
nothing pleases me more I get no no more
joy out of anything like being in a room
with like other really talented writers
and just like chewing the fat and
talking about story
um it's obviously very very common in TV
uh it's pretty much how all TV is made
it's become increasingly common in film
like they'll for example like I did this
recently for a project where they had an
idea from a studio had an idea for a
movie that actor had brought to them the
actor comes in and says I want to play I
want to play this kind of character
develop let's let's develop that story
and so they'll assemble a bunch of
writers who
um uh are very well paid to sit in a
room for a week and just talk about
story and one person runs the room and
puts ideas down on a whiteboard I've
done that on several I did it on
Sherlock Holmes three uh for for Robert
Downey with movies uh they do so they do
it they do it so they do them there's
various different elements of which they
used to do them on the back end so if a
movie is broken and they don't know how
to fix it they will bring in a bunch of
writers to brainstorm ideas how to fix
it uh it's very very common in comedy
where they'll just do they'll just have
comedy writers coming just to punch it
up and just basically pitch jokes yeah
what if this uh what if you said this
what if that happened
um and then but no it's increasingly now
happening on the front end where like
for example on Sherlock Holmes 3 they
knew they wanted to make a third one but
they didn't and all that and they knew
kind of what they wanted to do like
where they wanted to set it but they
didn't have a story and so myself and a
bunch of other writers sat in a room on
the Warner Brothers lot for a week what
if Sherlock did this what if Moriarty
did that what if Watson yeah what if
this happened and like you come up with
story ideas and then they and then the
person who's running the room takes that
to the studio and maybe they end up
writing the script or whatever and I've
done a bunch of those and it's really
fun and that's kind of what we did with
what eventually became forespoke and
they said I'd like to do a room and I
got to pick hand pick a bunch of writers
that I admire from film and television
and video games and literature and we
sat in a room in in a in La for a week
and just you know with this with the
executives the square the guys from from
square and we you know pitched a bunch
of ideas and came up with them and
here's how magic would work and here's
the history of the world and that kind
of stuff like the one thing that I know
that I contributed to the game is the
name of the world like Athea that was
just something I came up with and now
the world in the game is still called
Athea but that's literally the only
thing I know for sure of mine that's in
the game and then what happened was
um
some months after that they came back to
me and one of the other writers and said
we're going to start over and kind of to
completely reboot the story we want it
to be this now and what they pitched us
was something that's very closer to what
they actually have now which is about a
girl from The Real World that gets
sucked into this fantasy world that
wasn't anything that the version that we
did was nothing like that gotcha uh they
said we want this girl from you know the
real world to to get sucked into this
fantasy universe and the problem was at
that point neither me nor the other
Rider were available anymore because we
were too busy and they wanted to want us
to write the whole thing we both knew
what a huge undertaking is to write a
whole video game so he said look best of
luck with it you know obviously use any
of the stuff that we gave you if it's
compatible with this new version but
like we can't go any further yeah
um and then I think Amy and Todd came in
after us and did some work uh and then
and then they left and I think there was
a bunch of other writers that actually
wrote the game yeah
um but you know how but again we were
talking about this before we went live
you know how this works the the all of
the kind of the basement dwelling
Geniuses on on Twitter see my name and
they see Amy hennig's name and we're the
two most recognizable names as writers
attached we go oh you must have written
the game yeah and I'm like I'm not going
to go out there on Twitter and say I
didn't write any of it because I don't
want it to I I don't want it to I
honestly I honestly don't even know how
well the game has been received I don't
know what it's Metacritic is or if it's
good or bad like I honestly don't know
um but like I'm very I I go out on my
way and you can go on Twitter go search
my Twitter feed and and and find this
whether a game is good or anything I've
worked on is good or bad or anywhere in
between I will never ever play more or
less credit than I feel that I deserve
like for example this happens to me all
the time on Rogue one you know because
Rogue one obviously is the biggest thing
I've ever worked on uh and I will get
I'll get comments from people all the
time saying like oh Rogue one is so
great I love turret and beige those
characters are so poor and I will
immediately go well then you should
thank Chris whites yeah because those
are his characters they were not in my
script he brought those in after I was
done if it's something that I did do
like Vader's Fortress or the whole
business of like well you know the the
oh it was my dad that built that helped
build the Death Star now we've got to
kind of do that whole thing like I'll
take credit for the things that I did
but I won't take credit for the things
that I didn't and that's true if
something is good and that's true if
something is bad so if I say to you I
had very little to do with forespoke and
it's not because the the game is being
perceived as good bad or anything else
just because I had very lot to do with
it okay that's just how it is
um but it is irritating and I think what
it I think a lot of people are kind of
often show the whole ass when they go oh
Gary you did this or that when they have
no [__] idea what they're talking
about they don't know how games are made
right and and probably not a great
understanding of how games are made and
that's a thing that I think is or film
for sure and I think that's an
interesting um thing to ask you that
I've not had any other guests that this
applies to
everyone else that I've ever had on this
show has worked full time like
literally full-time employees start to
finish on a game that does not apply to
you so when you're being asked to come
in for something short like forespoken
that you can't stay on long term or the
story Consulting for Halo what is that
experience look like you're just in
there for a week and you just give them
a bunch of ideas in a room and then you
never talk to them again and is that
common
or is that something you think is like
no it's it's it's very it's very common
and
um uh now that there is
you know a an understanding in games
that writing is important actually yeah
um again I figured that out or I
wouldn't have a chart again I am old
enough to remember old video game
reviews where you know it was a common
Trope oh well you know there's not much
of a story but what do you expect it's
video game we don't we don't think like
that anymore right and develop and you
know back in the old days of game
development the story was handed off to
whoever had the least to do right yeah
oh you write the story and now of course
as you know Alana there's like massive
narrative teams and dedicated you know
they spent a lot of time is spent on
story and rightly so because I think the
expectation games have shown in the age
of
um you know God of War and The Walking
Dead and The Last of Us and all these
amazing these games that tell amazing
stories that it's there's no excuse
anymore to not tell a good story just
because you're a video game yes right I
think this is a struggle with some
studios where like someone who isn't a
writer has no writing experience thinks
that they know how to write and then you
end up with
a story that is not very cohesive or a
very frustrated writer's room we've
heard of that happening in a number of
Studios that I won't share
um where people who aren't writers think
they can write and it sucks for all the
other writers
that's what happens well again I work in
Hollywood just me I spend a lot of time
in rooms with people that don't know how
to write but they wear but they've read
one screenwriting book and they think
they know everything yeah
um
it's and it took a while for us to get
here once we didn't get everything right
like in that age you're kind of
interactive movies I remember a lot of
time they were just they would just say
well let's just bring in a big time
Hollywood screenwriter I mean and they
would bring in some big time Hollywood
screenwriter who's never played a video
game yeah who would pitch a bunch of
ideas that are completely not
appropriate to be told in a video game
format either like like scope is such an
important part of writing a video game
um where I feel like you probably don't
have to think about that in the same
capacity when you're writing a
screenplay and it was it was a learning
process for me as well I remember
sitting around the table
uh on The Walking Dead with Sean
vannaman
who was the Real Genius it's Sean and
Jacob the real geniuses Behind The
Walking Dead I was just lucky to be in
the room with them and I would pitch an
idea and they would say that's great but
there's nothing and they would they
would say that's great but there's
nothing for the player to do like
where's the player in all of this and
that's what you have to remember right
if the player doesn't if the player
isn't interacting all the time they're
going to start tuning out and now
they're just watching a TV show and who
cares there's already a Walking Dead TV
show and so it took me a while to kind
of develop that sense as well of like
how the pl you know you've got to keep
the player engaged yeah
um and but again we're better at it now
um the video game uh
big the big the big video game companies
have their own narrative people who are
experts in their field right you know
there are the kind of the Casey Hudsons
and you know the Matt sofases and the
people out there that are like they oh
they they live breathe and and and sleep
video game storytelling and they're
experts in that particular field and
then there are people like me that are
somewhere in the middle where because
they came from video games and still
love and play video games it's in my DNN
because I've done 20 years in Hollywood
I've I'm kind of bilingual and I
understand like why I I can also do it
and so people they and so they'll often
come to to people like me
um but it it's it's taken a while to get
there and like I said and we're still
learning like every every day is a
school day as we as we try to figure out
how best to like how best can we tell a
story in inside a video game yeah but
what are these sort of um like more
short-term consultant consultancies
sorry yeah sorry that was your that was
your actual question
um I really enjoy doing them I'm I'm
much more of a front-end writer than a
back-end writer and what I mean by that
is and I you know it's and I'd be a lot
richer if I was good at this but like
I'm not a script doctor kind of person
like I don't I I don't get I used to it
early in my career um get sent scripts
like uh here's a finished script but the
third Act is broken can you fix it I'm
not that kind of a writer I'm not good
at that oh you are yeah well you're
going to do very well Alana you're gonna
you're probably gonna be very rich
because that's where the real money is
there are writers in Hollywood earning
in the region of 350 000 a week fixing
scripts because look at it this way
right there are they they somehow got
ahead of themselves this happens all the
time in Hollywood they're literally on
set shooting burning millions of dollars
a day on crew and these Pages aren't
suitable right and so and and so if you
are the kind of guy like a
um uh I I don't know whose names are who
I would throw up but like there are
these people who who can sit in a
trailer on set and and fix those pages
on the day and and turn and turn a
non-shootable page into a shootable page
that's worth a fortune to the studio
right you say you are saving them so
much money it's worth what they're
paying you but my brain is just not
wired to do that I can fix problems in
my own script but for some reason I'm
not very good at like identifying what's
wrong with someone else's I'm better at
it yeah and I just I just don't like
rewriting other people I just don't like
it
um because I don't like no one likes to
be Rewritten and I I so I don't so I
don't like rewriting other people I'm
much better on the front end working on
working from a blank canvas where it can
still be anything where you can really
get your hands in kind of the raw clay
and shape what it is and and you can go
in any direction that's what I didn't
know for spoken that's what I did on
Halo you know those those projects there
was virtually nothing when I came in and
so I could pitch an idea that would
it's not like oh but the game's already
developed in such a way that that
wouldn't work like early that early in
the process any can think anything can
theoretically I'm sure a lot of people
would love to do that what was the first
game that you did it on
probably maybe gears that's a great one
to start with but I mean I didn't even
really do that much again it was just it
was it was really just Cliffy came to me
and said would you be interested in
helping me like figure out the world a
little bit and I wrote some stuff for
him I don't know if I even ever got paid
maybe I did
um
uh Duke Nukem pray the the original one
back in the day I remember I remember
saying to them you cannot have a Native
American character called Tommy Hawk you
just cannot do it you're gonna get
[__] murdered uh and they I remember
saying like what's wrong with it I'm
like do you do you really want to find
out and put the public then originally
and then eventually they called him
Tommy toodi
um but like you're gonna get murdered
seriously oh no
um but you know but you know here's the
funny thing you know the reason why they
uh why they actually changed it is
because they were they were worried
about Tony Hawk having a problem with it
wow like it wasn't even like oh no this
is like really racially insensitive oh
my God that's so funny oh my God I could
tell stories like this all day long
um the first one started because Cliff
approached you because like how does
that because I know because I knew
Cliffy from you know my journalism does
so so I guess that's also a tough one to
ask it's like again I've never had
anyone on the show before who's done
that kind of work how do you get into
that side of things I think there are
probably a lot of people who would love
to like just come in and do the Creative
Ideas type type of thing then then hand
it off that's that's something I'm sure
it's very hard but I'm sure a lot of
people I get I get asked this question a
lot like how do I get into games writing
and I think there's there's three ways
to do it one is you can go make your own
game you can be a Mike Bethel right you
can just look but you got to know how to
make the game you can't just write it
you've got to know how to build the game
around it you can be there are still one
man you know genius people out there
right like the like the like the like
the bethels of the world and uh you know
John Blow and the people that can that
can that know the story they want to
tell and they can build the game that
that tells that story you can get a job
at a video game company like start at
the lowest rank the lowest rung on the
ladder and and work your way up to
getting on the narrative team right
internally we had uh one of the writers
who worked on uh God of War Ragnarok uh
started in uh QA and right basically
expressed to one of the other writers
that she really wanted to write and then
she did and she helped out with a bunch
of uh Freya scenes and did a fantastic
job and I love that the studio gave her
that opportunity too they were like yeah
let's do it I think that's a legitimate
way you know you got to start at the
bottom
um you can I don't know too much about
the academic group like you know but I
know that like full sale and places you
know that that specifically teach kind
of game
narrative and game design courses I
think those are legitimate ways in game
developers and Publishers do look at
people that have those that have those
accreditations
um or you can develop your you can do
what I did and develop your reputation
as a writer elsewhere right so I was a
screen I was a screenwriter uh film
television I was a novelist comic books
like like people knew I could write yes
um and they also knew that I knew video
games so it wasn't it wasn't a big
stretch to imagine that I could also
write a video game reputation is an
important thing that I've also never
spoken about on this show
um I've said this before but like I've
had people criticize me I'll be like you
only got a job because you have a
following uh where that applied to Santa
Monica Studio
and my attitude towards that is no I
didn't my attitude towards that is well
that's an asset that I built to help me
be employable like if you see that as
something that that helped me get a job
then use it to help you get a job too
which is exactly what you've you're
talking about here really Gary is like
you and your Cliff you you know people
you have a an established reputation in
a field that can help um and I think it
certainly does if you want to do the
kind of thing you do which is be hired
for who you are you are hired because
you're Gary with her and people know
your your body of work do you have any
approach to how to tackle that side of
things like to to get your name out
there to make sure that people want to
work with you specifically you've just
gotta there's no easy answer you've just
got to do the work there's no shortcut
like it took me 20 years I've been doing
I've been I've been writing
professionally if you include my
journalism career
um for 35 years 20 years of that in
screenwriting yeah
um and I'm at a point now where yeah I'm
very well established and you know
there's only a number of job I
won't tell you what it is because I'm
not allowed but like I just booked like
a really big video game adaptation like
a live action thing and I got it because
partly because
of who I am and they know I can do the
job and I pitched them a version of the
movie that they were like oh wow like
you've actually cracked it and like I'm
gonna write that movie that's awesome uh
but it took me 20 years to get there uh
and there's no easy there's no easy way
to do it like I used to get questions
people always like they want the
shortcut like how do I get an agent uh I
don't have you written a script yeah
like it's like you've got to put one
foot in front of the other I'm actually
curious about your store because I still
remember vividly Alana when you and I
and Mike were on the xcast prior to the
show you said hey guys I'm not going to
be able to do the x-cast anymore because
I'm gonna go work for Santa Monica
Studio and we were like oh wow that's
amazing but like how did that how did
that happen because obviously like you
are obviously I know you're a writer I
know that you are you know you're a
Critic you're very creative you you know
you've got smart thoughts about video
games and stuff like that but how did
that how did all of that like how did
you parlay all of that into actually
kind of crossing the barrier into now
working in game development I worked at
Rooster Teeth as a stepping stone to get
and I've said this even when I worked to
get into game writing which is what I
wanted to do so I went from journalism
Rooster Teeth was a middle ground where
they did fictional content
um like they have Ruby they have video
games they had
um when I was the Arizona Circle so like
fictional stuff that I could get
professional experience writing on and
then moving from there but I also did a
lot of game jams so some of them under a
different name that are published you
can play game Jam games that I wrote on
um to get that experience
and I've written on three Indie Games
one of which has been announced that I
posted about on Twitter forever ago two
others that haven't
um so it was basically that part of it
was me just like really being like I
want to get this experience to write
things because I want to write video
games so just making sure that I did
that however I could
uh and actually getting to work there I
think the thing that is the biggest
credit to me because Santa Monica Studio
was not the first conversation I had
like it was a junior role that I had to
apply for and you know I had interviews
with 20 people whatever I had to submit
writing samples that I thankfully
already had and I was able to submit
other things that I had worked on in
terms of video games as well um
including one that I'm hoping gets
announced pretty soon which is like a
game people
are excited about in any case
um I think the thing that helped me more
than anything was that I had met people
there so like I knew people at Santa
Monica Studio already and had worked
with them before but that I anytime I go
to a dice or GDC or whatever uh I just
talk to people very enthusiastically
about video game writing and thus I
think it made people consider me for
video game writing things because I was
just there talking to them about the
things they think are good and the
things that I want to do no that's smart
wait I've had people say to my face
before I started being a video game
writer people in Dev you should be
writing video games that's the thing
Corey said to me you should be writing
video games
um and so it was just
making sure I had the experience and
accruing the experience obviously a lot
of it came from like it started with
University obviously studying
screenwriting I studied some stuff that
like is akin to game design in terms of
narrative but wasn't a game design
course at the time
um getting the experience and also just
meeting a lot of people establishing a
name and telling people that that's what
I wanted to do and then eventually
someone's going to be like you have some
good ideas I like those
you do you want to work with us and
that's that's pretty much how it
happened but similarly to you I've been
doing it for 12 years so it took and
this is and and that's and you and I are
great examples of how like like your
story is like totally different to mine
right in terms of how we both got you
know our game writing journey and so
it's it's no there's no it's it's not
people ask people to tell how you're
broken so I'm happy to tell you like
anecdotally but like oh press things
started the same way yeah I was 17 but I
was doing the same thing which is
basically just I was writing reviews in
my own time for fun right and then I
eventually just started submitting them
to people for volunteer work and I was
like let me write for you and I wrote as
a volunteer for over a year
and then pitch to a magazine and a print
magazine was my first ever paid writing
job was I I've had a review of Company
of Heroes published in the print yeah it
was mine too yeah
I'm saying I spent a lot of years in
like kind of Legacy Media film and
television and then kind of came in
sideways where I think you know again
your your route was somewhat different
and this is why when people ask me how I
broke into screenwriting they're asking
me hey because maybe they're just
interested in the story but also because
they like what can I learn and I always
say like I'll tell you anecdotally what
my story is but like it's not I don't
think it's replicable like I don't think
anything I can I don't think there's
anything about my story where someone
else would go oh I'll go do that no I
suspect that of the screenplays I've
written I don't have a ton of interest
in publishing them but um if I were to
get one sold I don't think it would be
that difficult for me to do and I based
that on the people I know at this point
in that I have one that I was like this
actress would really like this and I was
like when I finish it I should just give
it to her and I know that she has the
resources to get it made if she likes it
um and when I was writing it I was like
oh it suits her a ton I should just give
it to her and then she would be like if
she likes it she'd be like oh okay yeah
let's make this and that's very easy to
do but it's just a result of me existing
in similar spaces as people who work in
that industry and I don't know how to
tell someone to do that either and like
I said again I'm in that position as
well where like if I wanna like for
example again I I don't name names
publicly but like for example there's a
a TV pilot that we're trying to put a
director on right now and like the three
top directors who would would be
gangbusters for it like I just I know
them personally and I just like there's
no agents you just call them up hey you
want to hear a pitch yeah and five
minutes later you're in Zoom with them
yeah because I've been doing this for 20
years but like that's the it's not the
answer that people want to hear but like
the true answer is like oh how do I do
what you do well it's been 20 years
failing and getting rejected and beating
your head against the wall and thinking
about quitting and hating yourself and
having existential crises and going to
therapy and asking yourself why the [__]
you do this for a living and eventually
maybe you'll have some success whatever
you know I have this great that I have a
screenshot of that I haven't deleted
that was when I was still writing as a
volunteer and I was desperately trying
to find a way to make money writing
video games
how far back are we going
I think it's from 2012. okay and I said
something on the lines of like I'm so
close to quitting I'm I I is someone
someday going to pay me to write about
video games I don't know if I can do
this anymore it was like something along
those lines and I love that that's still
there the fact that I have that as a
thing that like is like yeah you did do
it and I had every opportunity to give
up and the failure is the thing we don't
talk about a lot I applied for a job at
IGN six times before I got one uh six
times I didn't just apply and then get
hand at a job like it was a job that was
so unrealistically perfect for my skill
set that was after University like all
of it like none of it's easy
um and I think you're probably right
that the getting to know people part
which makes everything a lot easier is
just a result of having to have um been
okay with failing many many many times
it's so funny I was on a I did the
x-cast yesterday
um and they had the developers a
knockout City on there and then knock
out cities just you know is is getting
sunseted and it was you know the guys
were there and
um I said I'm glad to be here with you
talking about failure because I'm an
expert you know I've been doing this for
a long time
um and I the one of the wisest that I'll
just repeat what I said on on the X guys
yesterday one of the wisest things that
anyone ever said to me and I use it when
I talk all the time publicly about
writing is uh failure is not the
opposite of success it's a part of it
it's a necessary part of it and I think
there is a certain amount of Darwinism
um natural selection that happens in
writing or in any field really where the
people who quit are the ones who are
supposed to yeah for sure right because
they can't they because they can't hack
it and I've come close I never came
close to quitting early in my career
because I always felt like no if I just
I'm going to keep going I had set back
so no I'm going to keep going I'm going
to keep going I'm going to get there I'm
going to get there and then I wrote Eli
and that and the door started to open
for me uh but like even as a like no
one's immune to this like even as an
established I was talking to someone the
other an A-list writer higher on the
totem pole to me just got devastated
heartbroken rejected on this thing
doesn't matter how big you are you're
gonna get kicked in the [__] face all
the time
um I remember on mouse guard which is
one of my favorite things I ever wrote
um everybody loved the script 40 it was
a major movie at 20th Century Fox uh had
a big time director attached 40 million
dollars in previous sex costumes Idris
Elba Andy Circus six weeks from
production Disney bought Fox and shut
down the movie because they just decided
they didn't want to make it under the
new regime when I got that phone call I
threw my [__] phone against the wall
and my wife had to come into my office
to ask if I was okay and I was like no
I'm not [__] okay yeah and and I and
they called me back and said the
president production of 20th Century Fox
wants to call and apologize and explain
to you what's going on I said and I I
said I don't I said don't put him on the
phone with me because I'm going to say
something I'm going to regret because I
was in a really bad I was in a really
pissy mood yeah that and one other time
with the other the two closest times
I've come this [__] close to quitting
the business I wrote a letter one time
to a person involved in another project
and I showed it to my wife and I said
just should I send this and she said why
don't you sleep on it yeah before you
send it and the next morning I was so
glad I didn't send it because I do like
remember I said about not taking [__]
from anyone earlier like sometimes that
can work against me and I can push back
too hard you gotta you gotta like never
make decisions In the Heat of emotion
right and like take it always take a
count to ten or however long it takes
take a minute to cool off but like the
point I'm making is
both of the times I have come this close
to quitting the business I really was
this close I was literally thinking
about how can I just get back into games
yeah
um were were when I was really really
well established as a writer and you'd
think you'd be immune to [__] like that
by now but you never ever ever are no
not if you care well that means you're
in there no no and that's the thing
Alana is you could only do this job and
you can only do it well if you give a
[__] yeah right you can't just phone it
in and the problem with it is when you
fall in love with a piece of material
especially it's something you created I
mean mouse guard wasn't something I
crave I [__] love that script I love
it so much it's my second favorite thing
I've ever ever written and it's so I
know it's good like I'm one of those
like really writers like is it any good
I don't know I'm really neurotic but
like I [__] know that's a good script
it's easily was well and not good enough
to get made as a 150 million dollar
movie and it got killed for no reason to
do with the script at all it was just
corporate mountain gods of Olympus
[__] yeah you know decided they were
gonna do something else
and you're never you're never immune to
that and honestly when you get fired or
uh Rewritten or a project that you put
your heart and soul into gets canceled
you honestly or at least I do honestly
process it in almost exactly the same
way that you process like a romantic
breakup was it me could I have done more
I hate the person but I I still want to
be with them like is there some way I
can fix this like it and you agonize
over it I don't know I mean I don't know
how much of this is like relatable to
you because I'm just like I'm very
emotionally fragile person so this is
how I deal with it but I don't know but
that's it's [__] hard and but the
thing but again it is it is also just
like romantic love right after a really
hard break it like never again I'm never
going to put my heart on the line again
but of course you you do you get over it
and of course you do because what are
you gonna do but be alone for the rest
of your life never write again of course
not no and I actually suspect that
for all the questions about like how do
you make contacts how do you find an
agent that kind of thing
um
if you and I are both people who can
find writing jobs because we know people
which you certainly more than me but I
do feel that way about myself too
probably a lot of that comes from loving
it so much that you are willing to deal
with the failures
um and and the sustainability like you
said it's if it's been 12 years for me
and over 20 for you
that is something that probably happens
inevitably as long as you do it for a
long enough amount of time and you don't
burn the bridges when you fail and you
don't just like Scorch the earth when
something goes wrong and that you keep
pushing forward then for every time that
I've submitted something to a studio
Santa Monica Studio is not the first
Studio that I applied to as a game
writer there were others that I got
really far and didn't get the job
because somebody had slightly more
experience or actually for all of them
it was someone who's slightly more
experienced it's very hard to find a
junior job in the industry to be honest
um but all of those Studios that I
applied for that I had interviews with
and that read my samples are now
contacts that I have who liked my
writing that I could potentially work
with again in the future on a different
project where I'm more fitting so for
every failure I still like met somebody
and spoke to somebody and for all of
them too the the studios I applied at
and didn't get work from I was really
like
hey what can I do differently or what
should I be focusing on like yeah
to be like what do I need to do to make
sure I want to do this so bad what do I
need to do to make sure that I can do
this and each one of them to their
credit sat with me and spoke to me for
30 minutes after telling me I didn't
have the job to talk to me about what I
needed to do or or whatever and uh that
it's it's the resilience I think that
gets you to the point where you know the
people you've got to have the resilience
you've got to develop some kind of
emotional careless and again the the
same reason
why we get so upset is the same reason
we I remember saying after mouse guard
I'm never going to write another Studio
Movie again I've written like five
since then and it's because we are
incurable Romantics right we love what
we we love what we do I love writing
it's it's also the only [__] thing I
I know how to do like I'm not employable
in any other field I can't do anything I
don't know I'm not good at anything else
it's the only thing I'm good at
um and so but what you but what you just
described Alana is exactly what I was
just saying like failure is not the
opposite of success it's a part of it
right and if you're and there's two
types of people that when they fail they
either get pissy about it and soul can
give up or they ask themselves what can
I take from this experience that I can
learn and apply to the next thing and
every failure has value if you know how
to dissect it and understand what you
can learn and it could be something as
simple as like there are a handful of
people in Hollywood that I will never
work with again because I know that
they're [__] and I will never ever
work with them again and they burned me
so badly for no reason you know anything
to do with the quality of writing just
[__] politics I have what I call my
life's too shortlist I will never work
with them again
we'll share it after
can you imagine what premium patreon
content
just other people don't want to work
with like name your prize for that one
um but it's sorted but it's also just
like just don't do it that way again
I'll give you a really good example
um I gave up a long time ago writing
original sci-fi spec scripts and for
people that don't know that spec script
means expect means speculative right it
just means no one asked you to write it
you just decided to write a script on
your own and when it's finished you say
hey I really need to say well I want to
make this movie that's how the Book of
Eli was made that was a spec script
um and there isn't much of a spec Market
in Hollywood anymore there used to be
there isn't any more because now
everything's branded franchise and that
is that kills me right I mean I do
franchise well I'm written on Star Wars
I've written on you know Walking Dead
Halo
um you know all kinds of of other stuff
that's like that's well known Batman
uh all kinds of stuff but like the stuff
that I care about the most is the stuff
that I create out of whole cloth the
original stuff it's mine and only mine
like for example if
if I hadn't got the Rogue one job
someone else would have written the
movie instead right that movie was
getting made no matter what it would
have been a different movie because
someone else would have you know helped
ride it but it's Rogue one would be out
there in some different form but if I
don't come up with the idea for the Book
of Eli no one else doesn't that movie
doesn't exist and so for that reason
it's more special to me and so the
things that I care about the most are
the things that Hollywood least wants to
do which is original genre material that
might be expensive
um but no one's ever going to make it
I'll give you a good I'll give you a
good example like The Hunger Games right
if Suzanne Collins had written The
Hunger Games as a spec script I
guarantee you no one's ever heard of The
Hunger Games no one makes that movie
yeah sure but because she wrote it as a
book yeah which sold a bajillion copies
Hollywood was lining up to make it and
big stars and big money and all this
crazy [__] wait she's riding around in a
[__] Chariot and her dresses on fire
and there's a guy with blue hair these
kids are murdering each other like but
that Hollywood would do it because they
knew there was a market there yeah
Hollywood is an extra extremely
risk-averse business but if you prove to
if you remove the risk hey 50 billion
people bought the book They're gonna
show up for the movie then they will do
it but if it's like who knows if
anyone's gonna show up but here's it's a
cool story they ain't doing it yeah and
so one of the things I've learned
what's that except for a24 don't do it
well except for actually I get again
much smaller movies yeah less exposure
to risk right the more money you're
asking a studio to put on the table the
the grade the Lesser their tolerance to
towards sci-fi is probably pretty
expensive right and that's and that's
why the the the the the high end of the
market is dominated by Star Wars and
Marvel yeah and Harry Potter and all the
rest of it because they know there's an
audience there or
stf filmmakers like Christopher Nolan
where he's the reason to go see it right
that's the Christopher Nolan himself is
the brand one of the last people left
that can make big original movies
because he's a Spielberg like that's the
reason to go yeah right that's the they
are the they are the first yeah yeah
they are the IP I'm not and I'm not
anything like that level right so a long
time ago I gave up rating
if I have an idea for like a bit like so
gundog's a great example I'll pitch my
go type gundog into your favorite
podcast engine it's very very good
you'll enjoy it it's got a big 60-foot
tall Mech in it it's fun
um I originally wanted to conceive that
as a spec screenplay a live-action
feature film but I I've been doing this
long enough to know and to anticipate
all the reasons why Hollywood's going to
say no so that what you're talking about
right now is the stuff that save the cat
talks about
okay so like there's a lot of stuff in
save the cat that does touch on the
literal save the cat pot but um and I
don't think it's helpful to everybody
but like there's a part in it that it's
like if you want to make money write a
Christmas movie
they're so safe for Studios um and it
does have some stuff about it yeah and
residuals every year every Christmas
forever I have three Christmas movies in
development right now because I want to
be Hugh Grant about a boy who's just
living off Christmas residuals forever
and never has to work again
um but no okay so this so I did this so
several years ago I had an idea for like
this medieval horror fantasy thing
called Abomination but I know for a fact
I can visually revisualize it right now
I'm in a room at Paramount or fox or
wherever and I've got my little bottled
water and we've done our small talk and
they'll go like okay what have you got
for us today Gary okay it's 10th Century
England and I can see the [__]
executive switch off right away we're
not making it really expensive but I've
got a nod politely for the next 15
minutes while this guy explains this
movie that we're never gonna make
um yeah it doesn't matter how good it is
is kind of the problem you can write
something incredible but if it's not
makeable if the algorithm says no yeah
it's a no yeah and uh you know so the
period movies don't make money yeah all
right well this is too expensive or
whatever is you know they've got all
their reasons to say no the default is
always a no the default when you go into
Hollywood meeting like that the default
is not neutral the default is a no yeah
and you have to turn it into a yes which
is that much harder and I again I've
been doing this long enough now to
anticipate I've heard every single
reason possible why they passed on a
pitch or a piece of material and I've
learned to anticipate it and it's
heartbreaking for me to spend six weeks
to anywhere between six weeks and six
months writing a spec screenplay that
goes out to Hollywood 15 20 people read
it they all pass and that's it it's dead
I spent six months writing somebody that
20 [__] people in the world will ever
read yeah right and now it sits on a
shelf and it's done
um I don't want to do that anymore it's
a waste of my time I want my stories to
find an audience and I'm a screenwriter
primarily that's my first language is
film and television but I just want to
tell stories and so I instead wrote
Abomination as a novel and that got
published and people liked it and it and
it found an audience and so that's the
end get good but guess what it's now
also a piece of Ip now now if they want
to make a movie they're adapting a book
and that's a different equation so with
gun dog I did a similar thing it's like
no one no one's going to make like so
make the live action version of gundog
would be like 100 million dollars like
60 foot tall Mech battling aliens in
post-apocalyptic America very very cool
but like No One's Gonna Make it yeah
right unless it's good
which again why because everybody knows
Godzilla because it's a franchise it's
an IP every now and again like sometimes
it only takes like one Spielberg or Del
Toro to find the script to go I'm
obsessed with this and then it's getting
made but like that's you know that's a
lottery you might as well buy a lottery
ticket and so rather than do that I
wrote it as a book which again I know I
can get Paul even if I have to
self-publish it I know I can do it I
know I can find an audience and so I
wrote it so gundog I wrote as a book I
did I produced my own audiobook
adaptation of it during the pandemic I
called in some favors very cool by the
way thank you very much so Shannon
Woodward came in uh your friend in mind
Troy Baker came in and did some voice
voice over your friend of mine Austin
wintry wrote this beautiful soundtrack
for it and it ended up being this really
successful thing we haven't published an
episode of gundog since November it
finished in November it is still the
number two most popular sci-fi podcast
in America wow that's mental yeah and so
now what's happened is aside from the
creative satisfaction of me knowing that
the story found in audience and was well
liked now when we go to Netflix Disney
HBO Amazon Apple whoever for the screen
adaptation I can say hey look this isn't
an original it's based on this
tremendously successful piece of Ip so
so creatively it works for me I get to
tell my story and commercially it works
because it's a different proposition for
the studio yeah so that again that's for
example that's an example of learning
take what you can learn from failure I
got tired of writing spec scripts and no
one was going to make what what can I
learn from this well Hollywood doesn't
like making big expensive original
science fiction films from from a writer
no one's ever [__] heard of yeah
whether I've done a Star Wars movie or
not that really only takes you so far
and so let me find another way to do it
and what yeah what you've done is is
figure it out rather than give up sort
of the point like and a lot of people
would give up and be frustrated because
again it's not necessarily about how
good what you wrote is it's about how
makeable it is the quality of the
material is it's irrelevant the quality
of the material is important but it's
not the most important thing what what
will ultimately get a studio to pull the
trigger and write like 100 million
dollar check is is there an audience for
it yeah can we Market it how much is it
going to how much is it going to cost to
make are we gonna make money basically
are we going to make our money back yeah
and that's a different equation in the
world of streaming because you know when
you release a movie at the box office to
make and market a movie costs a certain
amount of money versus what it makes at
the box office and then ancillary right
there's there's there's a number there
that come that comes out you either come
out ahead or not yeah
um but with streaming is obviously much
more complicated right because you don't
know it's just like oh this is this
movie on Netflix made this much money
that's not how it works no apparently I
was talking to somebody recently who's a
produced and they were saying that that
currently just isn't enough data like
they don't even know how it works yet
there is just not enough data available
for even the streaming services to know
how that correlates yeah and it is
becoming more algorithm I mean it's it's
fascinating you say there isn't enough
because like one of the things that
Netflix has like I'll I'll tell you this
this is my my prediction if Netflix is
ever sold in the future down the road to
like apple or Amazon or one of the even
bigger companies the the value of the
greatest value of Netflix is not the
library although that you know their
Library original content is now very
impressive it's not the number of
subscribers they have although that is
also very impressive it's that [__]
database they have yeah they know so
much about Their audience right and the
problem with it is now you know we talk
about like ai ai is going to come along
and take all our jobs and it is I think
Riders have got probably about three to
five years left
um and so like make hay while the sun
shines but for right now again like
again I don't know exactly how it works
at Netflix or apple or Amazon or all
these kind of algorithmically you know
LED companies but like it's no longer
just done on like a creative Executives
like gut instinct anymore like Summit
gets fed into an algorithm and the
computer says yes or no it changed the
way I do all of my YouTube thumbnails
because of Netflix I was like clearly
they know how it works clearly they know
what gets me what do they do and I
looked at a bunch of Netflix thumbnails
and was like do that so now it's just
did you know did you know that one faces
oh yeah You Gotta Have Faces Did You
Know by the way that when you and I
browse Netflix and we look at the same
show we don't necessarily get the same
thumbnail yes because in my household
every time that we browse Netflix and
there's anything that rahul's in we get
rahul's face right all of them right so
like if you look at fly man or midnight
mass some people will have like for
midnight mass they'll have like a church
we have a picture for a whole let's
time and I don't I don't imagine Netflix
like been like oh well Rahul Kohli uses
this account let's give him his own face
I don't think that's what happened but
let me let me give you another example
I'm not talking specifically about
Netflix or any company in particular but
I know this I know for a fact that this
is a thing that happens now let's say
for example that you and you in the past
have watched a lot of romance movies
right a lot of movies that have romantic
content definitely not but yeah and
there's definitely not
come on you're not are you not a
romantic no and it's the one thing I
can't write
let's say that you've watched okay let's
say that you've watched a lot of action
movies right and there's a new movie on
Netflix or Amazon or apple or whatever
streaming service there is a combination
of action but there's also a lot of
romance in it right and I've watched a
lot of romance and I've watched a lot of
romance movies you are going to get a
thumbnail that presents it as an action
movie I'm gonna get one that presents it
as a romance movie because they're
because it's bespoke marketing to each
of us yeah and these streaming services
don't just like don't just know what
movie you watched they know exactly how
much of it you watch they know if you if
you if you tapped Out are like 16
minutes and 47 seconds into the movie
they know that they know how long you
lingered on a thumbnail before you moved
on to the next one that that data is
it's it's this wealth and whether or not
whether or not it all adds up to
something that actually makes sense we
don't know but like this is where the
business is going it's been increasingly
driven by by day
yeah you can't change it you're just
gonna you just got to get right with it
or I'll figure it out and then adapt to
it what are people looking at and what's
that data and what do we make from that
is an interesting one um I have to go
now uh obviously we could have done this
for hours
I gotta say this is the most fun I've
had in ages I love talking yeah thank
you yeah well I'll see you in a couple
weeks at dice okay I'm presenting two
awards at dice oh awesome your game is
nominating both of the categories that I
am uh presenting I am not presenting
this year because my game is nominated
for too many awards
champagne problem we'll take it thank
you for that yeah I was going through
the nominations the other there's like
oh there's like very few categories that
your games aren't that your game isn't
nominated and those are the ones that
like just like VR or whatever
appropriate yeah yeah but yeah but like
art Direction animation best game
designs
but I mean my goodness yeah what a
privilege it must be to work there it is
it's incredible and I every day still
feel like I should be paying them
they're keeping like I should be paying
you to let me do this and not the other
way around it's very weird like when I
got promoted I was like then you get a
pay rise with a promotion I was like
should I can I give you the money to
keep me working here this is crazy it's
it's a really wonderful place to work
but yes I will see you at Dice and for
everybody who will not see the two of us
at dice Gary where can people find you
and what are you working on right now uh
you can find me on less so on Twitter
because Twitter has gone in the [__]
toilet and I definitely bother with it
anymore I'm like what a mess have you
ever seen a tech product go downhill so
quickly what a [__] disgrace
um but I am on Twitter and it's just my
name at garywood a g a uh r y w h i t t
a and I'm also on
um twitch and YouTube at this under the
same uh name just my just my my full
name what am I working on right now uh
that's a whole other podcast they've got
a lot of stuff that's happening in the
near future none of which I'm at Liberty
to talk about but I would love to come
back and talk to you again when some of
that stuff is out there in the wild
stuff otherwise of course people can
find you on kind of funny where we used
to do a podcast together and the kind of
funny x-cast uh publishes
um every the week every Wednesday so it
records Thursday morning now me me Mike
in Paris uh yeah that was uh that was a
lot of fun we miss you over there you
were always you always great I'm always
happy to stop by come by and next time
you're up in the Bay Area come by and
we'll get you in the studio I will
actually be up
um the same week as dice have you been
um in the new studio yeah you've got to
go see it
stop by it looks awesome oh yeah they'll
be thrilled to have you they'll roll at
the Red Carpet for you I definitely want
to it looks so cool and such a credit to
them that that's what they did I mean
I'm so happy for Greg I mean you look at
I was doing their original little sad
bedroom where they started and look look
look where look where he is now it's
amazing yeah and and the fact that they
do it without ever selling out to
YouTube I think is the best part is I've
said this about kind of funny before and
I'll say it again is the thing that I
respect about them more than anything is
they never folded to what's easy to get
views on YouTube which is negativity
um and when you're running a business
and supporting people and hiring
multiple people I feel like like I won't
do that but I'm just me and I have a job
when they're not doing that they're not
going for the negative clickbait stuff
that's so easy to monetize on YouTube
but they have to support humans as well
as like it's it's really that's just who
they are like it's just there's it's
positive that's why I like it like
there's so little positive energy these
days especially on the internet and
again I scroll through the same YouTube
thumbnails as you and I see all the
grievance yep and I see all the outrage
and I see all the click bait and it just
it's so [__] depressing and so I'm so
glad that kind of funny have managed to
make a success they've proven that like
positivity can still be totally
attractive and lucrative yeah it's
awesome um shout out to them as well uh
but thank you for joining me Gary thank
you everybody happy to do it thanks so
much we'll see you next time